Great.
Okay,
so the question is,
what do you mean by in forced monogamy?
Well,
we could start by what?
I don't mean.
I don't mean taking innocent women at
gunpoint and handing them over to useless
men,
which is essentially the accusation.
You know,
it was really interesting
to watch that on full.
What I meant was that monogamy as,
as,
as something that's socially,
uh,
value is,
it appears to be essentially
a human universal.
That doesn't mean that human beings are
universally monogamous because obviously
we're not,
we could be serially monogamous and some
people are players and have multiple
partners and all of that,
but there's a strong proclivity across
no societies to tilt towards monogamy.
And the enforcement is social norms.
It's like,
well,
think about it.
It's,
I can't believe that I
even have to say this.
Your son just gets married
and he comes home and he says,
Guess What Dad?
I've been screwing around.
And what do you do with you?
Pat Them on the head when you say,
hey,
good work kid.
That's,
that's my young man.
Well,
no,
you're not happy about that.
And he doesn't tell you because he knows
you're not going to be happy about it
and that's in forest monogamy.
It's part of the social structure.
It's like what and what else is enforced?
Monogamy.
It's like,
well,
most people want a monogamous relationship
and if they enter into a relationship
with someone,
they're not happy if that
person goes and sleeps around.
Right.
Most of you do.
You wouldn't be happy if that happened.
It's like not being happy.
That's part of enforced monogamy.
It's part of this.
No,
and you might've noticed,
you probably did.
Polygamy is actually illegal.
You can't have multiple America partners,
similar caneously that's
enforced monogamy.
That's like in,
and it's an anthropological term.
It's been known for a hundred
years by anthropologists,
most of whom are left bleeding by the way,
because that's how it goes.
Monogamous social structures are one
of the ways that you keep children
raised properly so that they have a
relatively stable environment and that you
keep male aggression,
especially the aggression of young men
under some degree of social control.
It's not a mystery in the fact
that I got in trouble for that.
It's,
it's kind of a miracle.
It's like,
don't you notice that we enforce
monogamy in like almost every way?
And that the same thing happens all
over the world in all sorts of diverse
societies.
And then when we deviate from that,
that there's a price to be paid so and so.
That's why like I'm a New York Times
pariah is because I think that monogamy,
all things considered is a good idea.
[inaudible].